the gunman's wife says she is shocked
about this attack and she had no idea
what her husband was planning sooo
Hodgkinson was emotional as she spoke
yesterday to reporters outside her home
in Belleville Illinois she said she
thought her husband had gone to
Washington to work on tax policy I just
don't know what to tell you people I had
no idea this was going to happen and I
don't know what to say about it I can't
wrap my head around it
okay and I guess the investigation is
focused on both Illinois and the scene
of the attack in Alexandria Virginia
chip Reid is there in Alexandria with
the latest chip good morning well good
morning investigators are still combing
this baseball field trying to account
for all the rounds that were fired and
looking for any other possible clues the
FBI has already recovered two weapons a
9-millimeter handgun and a rifle a trace
of the firearms determined they were
legally purchased by Hodgkinson
ballistics tests are being done to
determine if both were used in the
attack the FBI says the shooters white
van has been processed inside that
vehicle they recovered a cell phone a
camera and a computer agents continue to
look into the shooters activities
including social media in the months
leading up to the attack his social
media posts paint a picture of disdain
for the Republican Party and for
President Trump they're still looking
into a lot of different questions
including how did he know members of
Congress were practicing at this field
and did he come here to target anyone in
particular
Charlie chip thanks